افق وزراء الطاقه الاوربيون في الاتفاق
على سقف لاسعار النفط والغاز الروسيين
وقرروا بحث الامر مجددا في اجتماع منتصف
الشهر المقبل الى ان الوزراء اتفقوا على
اليه مشتركه لشراء الغاز وقال جوزيف سكينه
نائب رئيس الوزراء وزير الطاقه الاجتماع
وزراء الطاقه المقبل سيشهد توافقا بشان
مساله تسعير الغاز
على محتوى المقترحات المقدمه من المفوضيه
لكي لا نحتاج الى مزيد من المفاوضات ونمضي
للامام في ما يخص مقترحات تحديد سقف
لاسعار الغاز سننتظر الى الثالثه عشر من
ديسمبر للاجتماع الطارئ الخامس هذا العام
انا سعيد بما تم التوافق عليه والمفوضيه
الاوروبيه ستبدا العمل فورا على المقترحات
بخصوص مساله التسعير
مع رئيس الوزراء العراقي
ستكون له عواقبه قيمه على اسواق الطاقه
العالميه مثل هذه الممارسات تتعارض مع
مبادئ علاقات السوق وكانت وكاله تاسه
روسيه نقلت عن المتحدث باسم الكربلائي
تعليمات بعدم تصدير النفط والغاز الدول
التي تضع سقفا للاسعار
[موسيقى]